SO, LAST HOUR WE WERE WITNESSED
TO AN EXHILARATING ACHIEVEMENT
BY NASA, A STEP TOWARDS A
PLANETARY DEFENSIVE STEM.
THE SPACE AGENCY DELIBERATELY
SLAMMED A SPACECRAFT INTO AN
ASTEROID TO CHANGE ITS COURSE,
WILL BE SOMETIME BEFORE WE KNOW
HOW SUCCESSFUL THE MISSION WAS,
BUT THIS IS WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE
FROM THE CAMERA ON BOARD THE
CRAFT AS IT APPROACHED THE
ASTEROID, AS WELL AS A VERY
EXCITED MISSION CONTROL.
>> OH WOW.
>> THREE, TWO, ONE.
>> OH MY GOSH.
OH WOW.
>> WE HAVE VISUAL CONFIRMATION.
>> ALL RIGHT.
[APPLAUSE] >> AND WE HAVE
IMPACT, THE HUMANITY IN THE
NAME OF PLANETARY DEFENSE.
>> THOSE ARE SOME PRETTY JAZZED
SCIENTIST RIGHT THERE.
I'M JOINED BY LEGENDARY
ASTROPHYSICIST NEIL DE GRASSE
TYSON OF THE AMERICA MUSEUM OF
NATURAL HISTORY, HE JOINS ME
NOW, HE'S ALSO AUTHOR OF THE
BOOK STARRY MESSENGER, CAUSE
MCPHERSON ACTIVES ON
CIVILIZATION.
SO, HITTING THIS ASTEROID WAS
SUCCESSFUL, IT HIT WHAT IT WAS
AIMING AT, BUT WHAT WILL NOW SO
DETERMINED TO FIGURE OUT HOW
SUCCESSFUL IT WAS?
IF IT WERE TO PUSH THIS
ASTEROID AWAY?
>> WELL, IT'S NOT AN ISOLATED
ASTEROID, IT'S A MOONLIT OF A
LARGE OR ASTEROID, AND I HAVE A
LITTLE GRAVITATIONAL DANCE THEY
DO, WHERE THE MOONLIT ORBITS
THE LARGER ASTEROID.
AND SO, A LOT OF THOUGHT WENT
INTO, WHAT WOULD BE THE BEST
WAY TO TEST IF WE CAN DEFLECT
AN ASTEROID?
AND ONCE YOU HAVE A VERY WELL
CALCULATED AND MID MEASURED
ORBIT.
IF YOU NOW GIVE IT A NUDGE,
THIS IS A HEAD-ON COLLISION IN
THIS CASE, YOU COULD THEN SEE
WHAT HAS HAPPENED TO THE ORBIT
AFTER THAT COLLISION, AND SO
IT'S BRILLIANTLY CONCEIVED AND
DESIGNED, I JUST THINK WE
SHOULD'VE BEEN DOING THIS
DECADES AGO.
>> SO THE PARTY CAN'T GET PAST
IS THAT WE NEED A PLANET
DEFENSIVE STEM.
THIS IS A DRY RUN TO TEST
TECHNOLOGY IN CASE AN ASTEROID
IS HEADING TO EARTH THE POSES A
THREAT TO HUMANKIND.
WHAT IS A CHANCE THAT ACTUALLY
HAPPENING?
>> YOU CAN BET THAT IF THE
DINOSAURS HAD NASA THEY
WOULD'VE DEFLECTED THAT
ASTEROID THAT CAME ABOUT 65
MILLION YEARS AGO --
TO NOT ONLY BE SMART ENOUGH TO
DEFLECT ASTEROID BUT HAVE A
SPACE PROGRAM IN PLACE TO DO SO
AND NOT DO SO AND GO EXTINCT
BECAUSE OF IT.
THAT WOULD JUST BE EMBARRASSING
FOR ME, AS A SPECIES.
SO THESE ARE BABY STEPS RIGHT
NOW JUST TO SEE IF IT WORKS TO.
SEE IF WE HAVE THE POWER TO DO
THIS.
AND THEN WHEN THE BIG ONE COMES
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S ENOUGH OF THESE
PRACTICE RUNS THAT IN FACT THAT
WE WOULD END UP SUCCEEDING.
NOTICES DEFLECTING IT IS NOT
BLOWING IT OUT OF THE SKY IS IN
SO MANY CINEMATIC SCENARIOS,
THAT HAVE BEEN PORTRAYED.
AMERICA'S GOT IT BLOWING STUFF
UP, AND LET'S GO TO KNOWING
WHERE THE PIECES GO AFTERWARDS.
SO IT DEFLECTED ASTEROID IS FAR
MORE SENSIBLE, IN WHAT IT WOULD
REQUIRE TO PROTECT OUR SPECIES.
>> I LIKE THE FACT THAT
EMBARRASSMENT IS HIGH ON YOUR
LIST OF CONCERNS.
DURING AN EXTINCTION EVENT.
IT MAY BE A LITTLE BIT LOWER ON
MY LIST, BUT I DO APPRECIATE
THAT, THEN YOU HAVE THAT IS AN
ASTROPHYSICIST.
SO IF AN ASTEROID WERE HEADING
TO EARTH, WOULD NOT TO BE ABLE
TO REPLICATE THIS MISSION, OR
RETAILER WHAT IT DOES TO A
SPECIFIC ONE?
>> YES, OF COURSE YOU HAVE TO
TAILOR IT.
THE CATCH HERE, IS YOU WANT TO
DISCOVER THE THREAT AS EARLY AS
POSSIBLE.
SO IT MIGHT BE WE GET AN
ASTEROID, AND THEN 1000 ORBITS
FOR NOW IT MIGHT HIT EARTH.
WELL MAYBE THAT'S EARLY ENOUGH
SO THAT IF WE JUST NUDGE IT
MAYBE ONE CENTIMETER PER SECOND
TO THE LEFT OR TO THE RIGHT, IN
SOME DIRECTION THAT IT'S NOT
OTHERWISE HEADING, THE ONCE YOU
GET THAT EXTRA SPEED, THAT
SPEED JUST ACCUMULATES IN THE
DEFLECTION ANGLE, AND YOU CAN,
WITH RELATIVELY LITTLE
INVESTMENT OF ENERGY, HAVE AN
ASTEROID COMPLETELY MISS EARTH,
IF YOU GET IT EARLY ENOUGH.
AND SO A BIG EFFORT OF A
MASSIVE NOW IS CATALOGING THE
ASTEROIDS LITTER NEAR EARTH
OBJECTS, AND ONCE YOU GET A
FULL CATALOG OF THOSE, THEN YOU
TRACK THEM.
ONCE YOU TRACK, THEM AND YOU
GET ONE DISCOVERED, THAT'S WHEN
YOU GO INTO EFFECT.
BUT I'D RATHER WE HAVE THIS
READY, EVEN BEFORE WE DISCOVER
SUCH A THREAT, I FEEL BETTER
ABOUT IT.
>> I FEEL BETTER JUST TALKING
TO YOU ABOUT IT, IT'LL DE
GRASSE, TYSON THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR JOINING US EVENING,
ALWAYS A PLEASURE.
>> AND BY THE WAY, YOU KNOW
THAT MOVIE DON'T LOOK UP, TO ME
THAT WAS A DOCUMENTARY, SO I'D
WORRY ABOUT THAT.
AND EVERYONE IS IN D